yeah  are you taking it oh my do you guys see  this is this where you bring the chicks  haha right behind us we've got the  Rickenbacker Causeway and this is  Biscayne Bay this is Miami you guys to  Miami  there's your little Haiti I mean you  definitely wouldn't see this  what sorry wouldn't be here  how longs it take on it now  cheers guys okay take gear  there's like street art everywhere yeah  it'd be a really bad neighborhood a few  years ago and a bunch of artists moved  in here and painted everything I think I  would come here you know it's cool  though to see the other side as a  tourist you think of South Beach you  think of the nightclubs Pina Colada yeah  doing as the locals do so I feel like  we've dragged you guys all night we have  to see the Sun Rise  everyone get in okay not believe it  yes  all right here's up for some breakfast